what was that a face just as quickly as
i'd glimpsed it it was gone it was cold
as death and twice as dark in here
seriously i'd i'd never been anywhere so
dark it was more than just the absence
of light it was like walking through
thick black water only able to see
inches in front of my face things move
slower than they should have every step
i took
further down towards some unknowable
destination the darker and colder it got
i found myself wondering is this what
dying feels like slipping down further
into nothingness step by step through
darkness that never ends it was a
stairway like jacob's ladder except
instead of up to heaven it was a one-way
trip straight down there was some
distant tinny whirring noise that i
couldn't quite make out the way things
sound when you're drowning i didn't know
what possibility was scarier that the
steps just went on forever and i'd be
walking until my bones turned to dust or
that something would be at the bottom
waiting for me in the dark the deeper i
got the more i got this sense that the
latter was true the way you can feel
yourself being watched or send someone
standing behind you an evolutionary
holdover from when humans still took
part in the world of predators and prey
and we were not the predators some part
of us is just built to know when true
danger is lurking nearby we're down
below patient and hungry i could feel
its malice rising up the stairs towards
me the way people in a skyscraper
catching fire can feel the heat coming
up from below and know it's already too
late for them for the first time my eyes
came into focus and i made something out
in the distance when i realized what it
was and worse how strikingly familiar it
was all i could do was scream that's
when i woke up drenched in sweat and
relieved to see the darkness of the
stairway replaced by bright morning
lights shining in through my bedroom
window my brother steve was standing
there with a concerned look on his face
he told me i'd been screaming in my
sleep and asked me if i'd been having
that dream again it made me feel like an
idiot but i had to nod and tell him yes
it was the same one this weird nightmare
i've been having day after day and
despite it almost always being the same
thing it somehow never got any less
frightening there was no way to even
describe the profound sense of dread i
felt walking down those stairs and
finally seeing what was waiting for me
below even though i could never actually
remember what it was upon waking steve
told me not to worry about it and toss
some clothes onto my bed he assured me
that it was probably just final stress
seeing as we were a mere few months from
graduating i needed to be up in adam
today we were touring one of our first
choice colleges my brother and i had
always been close even if we hadn't been
fraternal twins i think we still would
have been best friends all through
elementary middle and high school we
were practically joined at the hip so it
only made sense that when we were
getting close to graduation we wanted to
go to the same college we'd be friends
to the end till we were old men on the
porch and rocking chairs it so happened
that we were together in the end just
not in the way i'd hoped the two of us
arrived to check out the potential
college a few hours later it was a nice
day out the brightness of the sky and
the lush greenery across campus quickly
banished the bitter memories of that bad
dream high school hadn't exactly been a
picnic for me i'm the nervous type if
you couldn't already tell steve who was
the more outgoing and confident one
always looked out for me he'd always
been there whenever i was dealing with
bullies or academic stress but at
college i felt like i could reinvent
myself and become the kind of person i'd
always wanted to be as we hop from
building to building across the tour
checking out the different facilities
and attending a few sample lectures and
seminars i was only becoming more
confident that college would be the
place for me to finally bloom it was
perfect for me but despite this college
being exactly what i'd wanted in terms
of lifestyle and academic pursuits there
was a certain stain on its reputation if
any university is around long enough for
any building at all for that matter
weird incidents are bound to accumulate
some places have ghost or cryptid
sightings this college had
disappearances not just one or two six
different students and one janitor had
disappeared from the campus the people
had nothing in common except for the
fact that they frequented the college
ages races genders and majors varied
across all the missing people and none
of them had known each other no notes
were given no clues discovered no
remains ever found a number of the cases
are even still open today it's a
frightening thought that people can just
drop off the face of the earth like that
and never be found there are over half a
million missing person cases in the
united states back in 2020 alone it's
more common than you think still i
comforted myself with the knowledge that
thousands of new students came in and
out of the college every year and only a
handful of disappearances what were the
chances that something bad would ever
happen to me though to be fair every
person who actually did disappear in
their last moments thought what are the
chances something like this would happen
to me too we were several hours into the
tour when the coffee steve had on the
way over finally caught up with him he
needed to go bad so we asked our tour
guide whether there was a bathroom
anywhere around here she told him that
he could find one pretty easily on the
ground floor of any administrative
building nearby in the meantime we'd be
making our way over to lecture hall 2b
so he could simply catch up with us
there once he was done steve left and i
didn't think anything of it at the time
i was too wrapped up in the tour it was
only half an hour later when we were
finishing up and preparing to leave
lecture hall 2b and his absence from the
group suddenly became a lot more
noticeable i started feeling nervous
he'd just gone to the bathroom what
could be taking so long i ran through
all the more rational explanations in my
head maybe there was a long line maybe
the bathroom was out of order when he
got there and he needed to find another
one maybe he got a little lost on the
way there maybe he got a little lost on
the way back there were so many
perfectly rational reasons he wasn't
with us right now but as the minutes
dragged on each one felt a little less
likely and a dark pit of dread began to
form in my stomach it wasn't long before
i alerted the tour guide naturally she
tried to calm me down saying how likely
it is that he'd just gotten lost steve
was a smart kid he was thinking of going
to this college after all so he must be
smart it was a smattering of laughter
from the tour group still she put the
word out to her fellow staff members and
the search began despite trying my best
to avoid panicking the stats about all
those disappearances just kept flashing
through my mind what if we were the
unlucky ones what if steve had actually
disappeared just like the others and i'd
never see him again as the hours marched
on and he still wasn't found that was
all i could think about i i didn't want
to lose him i tried calling his cell
phone and texting him countless times
but got no response you can only imagine
my relief when i suddenly got a call
from him though when i heard the content
of the call that relief quickly
disappeared the reception was patchy and
his voice had a strange echo to it like
he was somewhere deep and cavernous
there was this other noise in the
background too this strange tinny whine
that felt oddly familiar i only caught a
few words from him before the call cut
out the door stay away it keeps going
something down here don't come looking
oh god if i was scared before i was
utterly mortified now i couldn't just
leave my brother in a situation like
this no matter what he told me to do i
had to find him somehow i just had to
nobody else seemed to take it seriously
but i somehow knew he was in the most
terrible danger that's when i decided to
head to the one place i believed he
would be the administrative building it
was such an unremarkable little building
hardly the kind of place where you'd
expect some terrible secret to be hiding
but dangerous things often hide in plain
sight things like the door it was one of
those things from steve's message that
had stuck in my head the door call it
instinct call it intuition call it blind
dumb luck but when i was standing in
front of an average looking door in that
unremarkable administrative building i
knew i was staring at the exact door
that my brother had been talking about
it radiated bad vibes dark energy was
practically humming off of it but i
wouldn't let that stop me perhaps i was
stupid going in without help while it's
easy to criticize from the safety of
your home it's worth remembering we do
silly things when we're afraid and i
mean this was my brother were talking
about here no one in the world was more
important to me than him no one the
second i entered the room beyond the
door something changed it was like
stepping into another world entirely the
air was thick and oppressive the floor
below me and the walls around me were
ungodly cold but most remarkable of all
was the dark even my phone's flashlight
at full power barely made a dent i don't
think i'd ever seen anything so truly
impenetrably dark outside of a certain
nightmare anyway that was when i finally
realized where i was standing at the top
of the stairs those
stairs the stairs that had been haunting
my restless sleep a single winding
stairwell down into the void every part
of me wanted to run and scream and hide
but i couldn't i knew that if it were me
trapped down there steve wouldn't have
hesitated he would have charged down
there and helped me now i had to do the
same for him after all we all know that
in real life there's no such thing as
monsters and how deep could a staircase
really go anyway that question was soon
put to the test as i descended down into
the pit i counted 13 steps each time
before reaching a small platform there
were strange markings and scratches on
the wall the further i descended every
footstep i took echoed on and on and on
i must have been walking for a solid 15
minutes traveling impossibly deep when i
finally heard something else i called
out steve's name but quickly realized it
wasn't him it was a little girl weeping
a few hundred feet below i couldn't tell
if she was afraid and pain or both but
hearing it put ice in my veins what the
hell was going on down there had whoever
taken her taken steve too what exactly
was i dealing with these were the
questions racing through my mind as i
got deeper and deeper into the belly of
the beast time ceased to matter as the
flights went on and on beneath me even
descending into deeper colder darkness i
was literally walking into my own
nightmare but seeing as the only
alternative was leaving my brother to
die down here i couldn't do anything
else i was down countless flights of
stairs when i finally saw him he was a
distant pale speck dithering and afraid
he was a full flight down for me i was
so happy to see him that at first i
didn't even notice anything was wrong as
i got closer i began to realize that
this wasn't the steve i knew the dread
crept into me spreading through every
cell like a virus i finally knew why i
recognized it it was the thing for my
dreams the monster whose appearance
always brought those terrible nightmares
to an end but what did it mean to see it
in real life it was steve's face but it
seemed larger and deathly pale i froze
and as the face drew closer to me i
realized it had no irises no pupils no
nostrils and no mouth it wasn't my
brother it looked like a terrible
death-like mask modeled after him i
tried to scream as it appeared right in
front of me just as i had in my dreams
but it was too late long gnarled fingers
curled around my torso and crushed my
ribs it was a pain more intense than i
thought possible and soon even my vision
went black as i was dragged down to the
darkness below the last thought on my
mind was stee i'm so sorry i couldn't
save you i couldn't even save myself
now go check out
scp-087 the stairwell and the secret at
the bottom of scp-087 explained for more
takes on the terrifying secret of the
stairwell